system has real consequences for
people's lives and it's often the most
disadvantaged people who pay the highest
price people pay far too high a cost and
have to wait far too long to send money
home to their families abroad the
current system is failing them the
financial industry is stagnant and there
is no digital financial and architecture
to support the innovation that we needed
I believe that this problem can be
solved and Libre can help the idea
behind Libre is that sending money
should be as easy and secure sending a
message Libre will be a global payment
system fully backed by a reserve of cash
and highly liquid assets now I believe
that this is something that needs to get
built but I get that I'm not the ideal
messenger for this right now we faced a
lot of issues over the past few years
and I'm sure there are a lot of people
who wish it were anyone but Facebook who
are helping to propose this but there's
a reason that we care about this and
that's because Facebook is about putting
power in people's hands our services
already give people a voice to express
what matters to them and to build
businesses that create opportunity
giving people control of their money is
important too and a simple secure and
stable way to transfer money is
empowering over the long term this means
that more people transact on our
platforms that'll be good for our
business but even if it doesn't I still
think this could help people everywhere
before we move forward there are
important risks that need to be
addressed there are questions about
financial stability fighting terrorism
and more and I'm here today to discuss
those risks and how we plan to address
them but I also hope that we get a
chance to talk about the risks of not
innovating because while we debate these
issues the rest of the world isn't
waiting China is moving quickly to
launch a similar idea in the coming
months Libre is gonna be back mostly by
dollars and I believe that it will
extend America's financial leadership
around the world as well as well as our
democratic values and an oversight but
if America doesn't innovate our
financial leadership is not guaranteed
I actually don't know if libras gonna
work but I believe that it's important
to try new things and as long as you're
doing so responsibly that's what has
made America successful and it's why our
tech industry has led the world so we
co-wrote a white paper to put this idea
out into the world and to start a
conversation with regulators and experts
and governance and today's hearing is an
important part of that process what
we're discussing today is too important
for any single company to undertake on
its own and that's where we help to
found the Libra Association it's a
coalition of 21 companies and nonprofits
that are working to give everyone access
to financial tools but even though the
Libra Association is independent and we
don't control it I want to be clear
Facebook will not be a part of launching
the Libra payment system anywhere in the
world even outside the US until the US
regulators approve last time I testified
before Congress I talked about taking a
broader view of our responsibility and
that includes making sure our services
are used for good and preventing harm
and I want to discuss that across other
aspects of our work today as well people
shouldn't be discriminated against on
any of our services we have policies in
place to prevent hate speech and remove
harmful content but discrimination can
also show up and how ads are targeted
and shown to as part of a settlement
with civil rights groups we've banned
advertisers from using age gender or zip
codes to target housing employment or
credit opportunities and we've limited
interest based targeting for these ads
too this is part of our commitment to
support civil rights and prevent
discrimination I also know that we need
more diverse perspectives in our company
diversity leads to better decisions and
better services for our community we've
made diversity a priority in hiring and
we've also made a commitment that within
five years more than 50% of our
workforce will be women people of color
and other underrepresented groups we've
made some progress here there are more
people of color women and technical and
business roles and underrepresented
people and leadership at Facebook now
but I know that we still have a long way
to go chairwoman waters ranking member
McHenry and members of the committee
this has been a challenging few years
for Facebook I recognize that
we play an important role in society and
have unique responsibilities because of
that and I feel blessed to be in a
position where we can make a difference
in people's lives and for as long as I'm
here I'm committed to using our position
to push for big ideas that I believe can
help empower people thank you and I'm
looking forward to answering your
questions thank you very much I now
recognize myself for five minutes for
questions
so if we have been listening there to
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg appearing
before a US House committee this time
defending the upcoming launch of
Facebook's at digital currency our
correspondent Shihab Ratan C is joining
us live from Washington DC I believe he
was also listening in to Zuckerberg
talking about everything from America's
democratic values to civil rights and
preventing discrimination and his
defense of Facebook's digital currency
Shehab that's his pitch look trust us
I realize that time and time again I've
disappointed you Facebook has been find
it's been sued it's been found to be
discriminatory with off with our social
media apps but this time it will be
different all we're trying to do is have
an altruistic financial service we just
want to create one a billion people
around the world don't have bank
accounts what if they did have access to
financial services surely everyone will
win if they can just transfer money as
easy as it is to send a text message so
that's one part of this message the
other part is and that's a bit more of
the jingoistic message which actually
did already seem to be appealing to the
ranking member the ranking Republican
member of this committee which is if we
don't do it China will this is about us
leadership financial leadership
technological leadership even there
actually
Libra will be based in Geneva in
Switzerland he didn't mention that that
but anyway but about that but these are
the two planks of his of his of his
argument here the problem is is even
accepted there its Facebook time and
again they all found despite the
pronouncements to be exploiting the data
they're getting from our social media
accounts and now they want to create a
private global digital currency which
decentralized how is that going to be
regulated what's gonna happen to all
that information what happens when you
have that information and are all of our
social media information Facebook and
Zuckerberg is going to say today look
what it's going to be strict boundaries
between the two but there's this issue
of trust secondly financial stability
the global financial system is is it's
pretty unstable as it is we got a boom
where a boom and bust cycle you know
every three years that's how capitalism
works because of partly because of
capital flows of currency going around
the world
now you want another digital currency
which a third of the world's population
may have access to through Facebook
Instagram whatsapp and all this money
sloshing around well what's that what's
that gonna do to all the other
currencies couldn't speculation start
couldn't speculation against national
currencies began that's another question
regulation in a decentralized currency I
mean who's in charge of this there as
well so these are all there's some of
the some of the issues he has to has to
face financial instability privacy the
currency being used for nefarious ends
with no oversight we expect those to
come up with but given this is Facebook
too we also expect other issues that
have dog Facebook to come up to it's
going to be a long hearing there's 60
people on this committee each has about
five minutes to ask questions so it's
going to be a long day for everyone she
helped thank you very much for that for
now that she have returns he live in
Washington DC thank you